the plaza hotel and casino announces
plans to
transform its corridor the area they're
talking about is main street right by
the greyhound bus station
sally jeremiah tells us about the
changes to that general area
the tree was actually probably a little
premature and my over excitement but it
is something
i've been actually since 2007. and that
tweet from plaza ceo
jonathan jossel on tuesday caught the
eye
of many so what's next for downtown las
vegas
on wednesday the plans revealed we did a
deal with the city
in conjunction with greyhound's
departure website there would be a
bridge and a pedestrian walkway
that would connect um basically circus
prematurely experience the plaza
and uh and the west side of symphony
park with these plants the greyhound
station will need to be
relocated it also provides us with about
two acres of space
uh whereby we can redevelop it into
something that's going to be very
complementary to the plaza to the
downtown area
and to future businesses and then there
was also the piece of well
greyhound sits on main street which is
right next to
our new neighbor across the street circa
it's also right next to the new 800
residential units being built jordan
jenkins moved to las vegas in august
from tulsa he is glad to hear of more
changes to this area
for the better and i can appreciate it i
just got off work and
went to come out and just take a walk
and just take him downtown to see it
during the daylight
jenkins hopes these changes will improve
the homeless problem
by greyhound and provide better
pedestrian safety it's been a difficult
year for everyone and a lot of bad news
i think that's probably why my tweet was
so well received just because people are
looking for good news out there sally
jaramillo 8 news now
that they are now the greyhound bus
station will be vacated by the middle of
next year no word where
it will be relocated